[Music]
black against ooh 2400 okay this one
might might be very competitive so let's
go to the caro con
this guy's 27 52
um blitz so he's good
all right
let's go with a tardical recaro
and i'm gonna go for my main line he
takes f6 this is what i play in blitz
often
and this is a very fashionable system
where we eventually we develop the
bishop to d6 then we castle
this is all theory and this bishop comes
out to g4 so this is all normal
and now the knight comes out to d7 i'm
i've talked about this setup before i
don't want to take too much time in the
opening because clearly we have a very
very strong opponent
okay h3
so we go bishop h5
and generally
white
i mean if white allows the bishop to
come to g4 as he did we've essentially
solved all our opening problems
so now we go knight d7
and then queen c7 rook e8 i mean it's a
very easy system to play the pieces
don't even have that many squares to go
to
yeah 2300s are good i mean this guy is
clearly
clearly clearly a strong player okay he
goes c4
all right so
there's a couple of ways that we can go
about playing this line
in general i like the idea of connecting
the rooks and also creating a little
battery here
we can also go c5 but that allows them
to create a protective passer with d5
although in that position we could go
knight e5 so
i like to move c5 as well
but
in such positions i don't like to play
very committally and i think we should
reserve the move c5 for later we're not
afraid of him going c5 because after
queen c7 c5 will have bishop f4
let's start by playing queen c7 and then
c okay g4 instantly
well that doesn't leave us much of a
choice bishop g6 c5
okay bishop f4 is forced i mean there's
clearly something i'm missing here
because
um this guy is playing very quickly here
i mean obviously he's weakened the
king's side tremendously
so i don't really believe in this for
white but there might be something
concrete that i am missing
yeah rookie 7 of course is
a possibility but i can even play rook
ada and i'm not too afraid of just a
single rook landing on e7
he's gonna need more than that to
to scare me all right h takes g6
creating the pawn cube
obviously not f takes g6 which would be
tremendously weakening
rook e7 all right so this is what he was
aiming for
i'm not too scared of this the knight
has no squares which is a little bit
concerning but fortunately we can defend
the knight with a rook
why do we go with this rook because we
want the other rook to defend f7 if he
goes queen b3 right now
if we had gone rook fd8 then queen b3
would have followed and we would have
been in massive trouble because to
defend that f-fun we would have had to
return with the rook to f8 and then the
knight would have been left unprotected
all right you know what i mean lawful
waffle
okay queen e2
all right so
if we can solve the problem of the rook
i think black will be better
due to our um
superior structure and whites weak
squares so
the plan here is to try to break free of
the chains
so how do we
how do we do that um
it's not so simple
it's not so simple
i think for a second yeah we can go g5
we can go f5 the problem with f5 is he
goes g5
five doesn't quite cut it
five doesn't quite cut it um
i have an idea
it's not the greatest idea in the world
but it's an idea
the idea is to go a5
and then to go b6 after that
and the reason that i don't want to go
b6 immediately
is because of b4 white would preserve
the bind on our position so first i want
to go a5 to stop b4
and then on the next move i want to go
b6
i don't love my position to be
completely honest but
i think if we can get b6 and we'll be
fine
all right so here even taking the queen
should be considered because if we take
the queen and he takes to the pawn then
we go rook fe-8
probably the end game is slightly worse
for us but closer to equality than to
anything
um we can also drop the queen back to ba
but then he goes rook a e1
and if we go b6 white can go b3
takes takes
very concerning position there so
probably we should take the queen
probably we should take the queen
and it's not a great position there but
yeah we're getting
slightly outplayed here queen back to b8
yeah this guy
this guy played hikaru and stuff so he's
clearly very very strong
no i want to go queen b i don't want to
take me i'll explain why after the game
but i think this is a better chance
thank you cronies for the for the five
gifted i appreciate it
all right
so if only we could go get rook feed and
we would be totally fine because the
knight would be able to park on f8
man very strong b6 okay let's try to
break free
no i have not lost on the speed run um
this is potentially my first loss if
he continues to play as powerful as he
has
okay we'll see
the position remains quite solid i think
i don't see a way for him to break
through
the move i'm worried about is b3 because
we are threatening to take on c5 and
then to take the pawn on b2
okay
okay let me think no he he's obviously
not sniping he's just found the move
let me think
okay probably we should take and go
queen before
so you can go queen before to attack the
pawn
okay
so maybe it's not so bad actually
see one
no it actually is bad
okay maybe f5 takes takes knight t4
uh maybe knight b8 is interesting to
open the d open the d file but then he
goes rook c4 queen a3
no that's all very bad
geez
okay worse comes to worse we can go
knight e5 here
i really don't like that
i can try the move queen a3
okay let's try queen a3
rook c2
okay maybe now knight b8
then he goes 94.
okay
or does he want to trap my queen of the
rookie 4 with a4
wow
that is insane
gosh i feel like an idiot let's go a4
maybe
let's try a4
yeah we have to try for open up some
territory on the queen side
obviously this is bad but
do what i can here
yeah i mean i it's hard to estimate his
level so far but
obviously so far he's playing at a gm
level
or i'm just playing below my level but i
don't even really know what i did wrong
to be completely honest takes takes rook
d2
yeah here i was thinking knight e5
here i was thinking 95 and maybe i can
squeeze out a draw though it's doubtful
because if knight b8 amazingly he's got
take stakes rookie winning my knight
which basically means i have to go 95
and hope for the best
well not random stuff i mean sack upon
and try to
actually pull out a draw here is what
we're gonna do
no it's not hope dress i mean we have to
we have to trade as many pieces as
possible here and then my king the only
thing that's working in my favor is that
the king is kind of safe okay we take
if he takes we take we can promote this
yeah 2400 in rapid is
really high but it's
i mean it should not be a gm level i
think
so let's see
rick takes e5
all right so here's the situation
if we play queen takes a2
then he goes rook e8 check
and then we trade on e8 and the queen
comes back and takes on c6 so i thought
rookie five was a mistake because i can
actually give this check first
i think i can give this check first and
then take on a2 on the next move
and i actually didn't see how he can
make progress in in
with respect to my king because if he
gives me a check on e8 i just go king h7
and i mean if his queen had a way to get
onto the eighth rank in one move i think
he would make me but
i don't see how he gets that done so
maybe
we're holding on here i don't know i'm
optimistic though
now he absolutely does not give uh does
not give off the impression of a cheetah
he's definitely legit i mean i'm 99 sure
he's not i'm not i don't get that sense
from him
he's just clearly extremely strong
that's all there is to it
okay so queen we got to calculate queen
a1 queen a1
there there wait let me calculate q1
no that's got to be good right queen
f3
you want king of four
22.
i think i have at least a draw there so
queen a1 is what i'm
currently
currently rolling over
but it probably also doesn't work he's
got there there
[Music]
yeah maybe i shouldn't do that how else
can i defend i can go rook d5 then he
takes it
i can go rig d2 maybe
but i don't really like that either
yeah maybe your d2 is forced
hmm
okay we can also risk it with kuni one
yeah let's risk it
let's risk it for the biscuit with queen
a one
i'll explain at everything after the
game but i gotta move let's go queen a1
if rookie ate king h7 and if queen takes
f7 there i start tracking him rook g1
etc
okay fill up no computer evolves come on
okay
this is
obviously
a highly concerning position but also at
the same time
uh his king is also very weak here so
i'm picking h7
queen f7 okay so we go for that line
rook g1 check is forced
king f3 queen d1 check
and maybe i have a perpetual there i'm
not entirely positive king h2 rook h1
okay
king g3 oh my god does he want to go
he wants to go to h4 doesn't he which i
of course i didn't see at all
my gosh what a what a defensive idea
queen c3 is possible
no but the ah but yeah maybe it is
possible
rookie three but then he doesn't have
that check anymore
yeah ricky three but then i can take on
c5 maybe and i should be okay
i don't know
wait does he have f3 oh my gosh
he might have f3 though
unreal
and i have no check so king queen is
dominated
[Music]
okay
what is he threatening queen g8
h4
yeah it's lost it's just lost
yeah well done
i don't think i have a defense i mean
maybe there's something but i don't see
it
yeah rook g1 he goes king up i missed
this move f3 completely okay i have to
do this
king h4 well
wait but this allows
f6
now i'm still more or less in the game
if he's not careful he can get
checkmated here
i guess ricky six wins
damn
still probably winning for him
jesus
okay
that's a very strange king h4 move
because he was just winning on the spot
there king h2
damn it
yeah i was hoping he would uh get
himself mated but he didn't
why did i do that i i should have
probably
i don't know what i should have done
who knows
h5 and there's no stalemate
unfortunately
incredible i mean unless
uh
so i can get a five in but okay let's
see how
look at five wins
i mean
you just played incredibly well i don't
know what to say
yeah this is over
i guess the speedrun lasts a little bit
longer
oh okay
wait wait wait i'm still lost i'm still
lost that's the [ __ ] that's the
amazing thing
i'm still probably lost
this is ridiculous
this is absurd
i like how he just like didn't even
flinch
this is still
probably at least a drop probably a loss
wow
i like how he gained rating from this
game
yeah it's it's it's that's a position
it's a draw
that was very dirty but you got to try
everything
it's online chess
of course in my eyes i lost that game
okay let's analyze
um i mean of course the accuracy is good
oh my god 99.3 to 98.2
oh my god that's pretty crazy
no no no i this guy was legit i mean i i
didn't i completely did not get the
sense that i'm playing a machine i just
got the sense that i'm playing a very
strong human
uh we'll analyze with an engine
obviously but um
i'm also human like i i make mistakes
the point of the speedrun is not to
convince anybody that i am
to convince anybody that i am some sort
of superhuman
okay
do skeleco thank you for the prime
no there's no chance there's another
speed running yet so by the way i didn't
want to misrepresent the tardigrade
um
i didn't want to misrepresent i have
played him before
i didn't know that
um
i made a very crucial mistake here um
and the mistake was what i would call
chess related procrastination so do you
guys remember what move i refrained from
playing in this position
do you remember what move i refrained
from playing in this position
yeah so c5 please and
i'm not going to keep repeating this but
it goes without saying that
um baseless accusations are disgusting
and shame on you if you go around saying
like this guy is obviously a cheater or
like if he beat hikaru once he must be a
cheater i wish people knew how
ridiculous they sounded when they say
that
i'm also not trying to imply that i'm
that he's cheating when i say that he's
playing extremely well
which he is
um
and as you guys know if i suspect
someone i'm pretty open about it but i
don't do it without looking at the
engine moves checking the accuracy is
not enough it's possible to play a 99
game in a 10-minute game
but every time that you're like
streamer
of choice does not win a game
it's not right to resort to just like
accusations
okay um
so c5 would have been the best move in
fact it's the only move to keep equality
c4 c5
and if white goes d5 then after 95 black
is actually better now let's focus on
the analysis
um
and the point here is that if white
plays bishop e2
you play bishop takes f3 and white is no
good way to recapture gf3 is obviously
destructive and bishop takes f3 blunders
the pawn to c4
um
so c5 would have preserved
a decent position for black
unfortunately i didn't realize the
urgency
of this moment and quincy 7 was a
mistake
i completely underestimated his idea g4
is indeed the best move
and um i this idea got me completely off
guard i didn't understand the
significance of the c7 square which is
this is a pretty rare idea in this line
g4 c5 rookie seven
this was incredibly good
and now it's plus over minus so bishop
g6 yeah queen b8 but now look at this
rogue now queen b8 i think there's
bishop f5
attacking the knight so the point of
queen c7 is to keep the rooks connected
okay g4 bishop g6
c5
the problem with this for black is that
despite
my control over the weak at four square
now but it's not the space is not the
problem
in this line black lacks some space
that's one of the drawbacks of this
caracon line but that's not the problem
the problem is that this knight has
absolutely no prospects
um xagian thank you the knight can't go
out to b6 he can't go to e5 he can't go
to c5 and that's what kills me because
the bishops are traded and we're only
left with one minor piece each and when
your only minor piece has no squares
that's a huge problem
okay so bishop takes f4 queen takes f4
and
that problem outweighs my very powerful
queen on f4 i thought that
this queen would somehow compensate for
the bad knight but it actually doesn't
okay so this is all correct bishop g6
hg6 the computer still doesn't show a
big advantage for white a5 is the top
move
so i found a really strong idea here
i don't know how i find apparently i
made a brilliant move i don't know how
to find that
so a5 is the only move apparently to pre
to limit white's advantage
um again what is the idea of a5 so i
want what is black squall in this
position
black's
um
black's biggest goal black's only goal
is to somehow activate the knight on d7
and it's not necessarily to get it to b6
to get it somewhere i mean ideally you
would get it to d5 but that's impossible
now what's stopping the knight from
coming to b6
um well it's the pawn on c5 which is
controlling that square so that's why i
wanted to play v6
but unfortunately white plays b4 and if
you play a5 white plays a3 this is a
typical kind of sequence and you haven't
made any progress
okay
so a5
stopping b4 and i want to play b6 on the
next move and if white plays a3
what should black do here
okay i'm going to time people out for
making off topic remarks
yes a4 stopping b4 due to the on poisson
this is also a very typical idea you put
the pawn on a4 and then you play b6 on
the next move
so orange sting asks was it possible to
go for a plane like g5 f5 so again the
problem with f5 is that white goes g5
and stops knight f6
so an idea that was thrown out by the
chat was g5
let's say rookie one and now f5 yeah it
was possible
but white has this move queen e3
and an end game is quite terrible for
black because then you're just left with
this terrible knight you can't move it
and it was an interesting idea but i
don't think it quite solved the problems
of the position
okay
so a5 queen e3 is excellent
and now queen b8 is also good
and rook a1 activating the last piece b6
b3
and even though i've managed to open up
the position a little bit
um it's still very very unpleasant
because i still haven't solved the
problem by night
but i i have what i have done is
acquired the e5 square for my knight
so potentially i can put my 995 even at
the cost of a pawn
okay so queen b4
rook c1
and i think
according to the engine
queen before is the top move
and according to the engine what i
should have done is something very
clever here
i should have gone back to b8
um again really the only move to
preserve a reasonable position
oh what's the idea of this move well
the idea of this move of course is to
play rook f to e8
and get this damn rook out of e7
and obviously if white plays rookie one
then we are repeating the position i go
back to b4 and hit the c5 pawn again
so essentially
i'm going after two ideas at the same
time i'm hitting the c5 pawn in order to
get the rook off of the e file
and then i'm coming back to b8 in order
to prepare rook fe8
um to get the rook off of e7
um i just didn't spot that idea i
kind of went after his queen side
without fully realizing that
uh there's not a lot of prospects there
okay
um so rook c2 to defend the pawn and now
a4 there was one interesting detail i
almost played
i almost played knight b8
which actually loses on the spot
and the reason it loses on the spot is
quite a beautiful idea and that would be
rook e4
and the rook is coming to a4 and there
is simply no stopping that queen on a3
is totally boxed in and trapped whatever
black does
white goes rookie 4.
sorry rook a4 and the queen is lost
so this is
quite
quite amazing
um there's simply nothing that black can
do here that's why i had to play a4
that's why i had to play for he saw that
for sure yeah he
he definitely
um he definitely intended that when he
played rook c2
b takes a four is actually really strong
he takes a4 queen takes a4 and rook d2
and again there's a problem
because now if i go back to b8 white
wins a piece
rook takes d8 rook takes the
rookie 8 check
takes takes and there's a fork
and that's it i have to go knight e5 and
give up a pawn so knight takes e5 f
takes c5 rook takes the eight rick takes
state rock takes d1 rook takes e5
okay
so
there's another issue here which is that
queen takes a2 fails again to wiki 8
check
and this resulting end game is
completely lost for black
these types of end games queen m3 on one
side and then one pawn on the other side
is generally just lost
because as long as his queen stays on
this diagonal
and the king parks itself on g2
black will never have
any kind of checks on that long diagonal
so the pawn is basically free to go
this is losing
um that's a good thing to know by the
way these types of end games are rarely
salvageable
that is why and i thought that i was out
of the woods here that is why i played
rook d one check first and then queen
takes a2 according to the engine i
managed to essentially equalize
even though we've all played essentially
the top moves
so here he goes queen f3 which is an
incredibly strong move
um i underestimated this move i assume
that he would give me a check
after king h7 black is fully out of the
woods
black is fully out of the woods
um
because white has no way to get the
queen onto the eighth ring
and if he tries to sneak the queen to h4
then i return to d5 and actually black
is the one who's mating here because the
white king has no escape all of a sudden
um
so he goes queen f3 to kind of cover all
the important squares
and here i made the decisive mistake
when they won
queen a1 was the decisive mistake
according to the engine
it appears that i could only hold the
position by playing rook to c1
which is not really human i think to
give up the pawn like this but
apparently queen c4
gives black enough counter play to make
a draw as the queen comes to f1
and black will have some sort of a
perpetual there
but of course i didn't really consider
the idea of giving up the c6 phone and i
also wanted to create an immediate
threat against the king
so the other move that i considered was
rook d2 this would have been better than
the text move
but still white has a big initiative
after rookie 8 and rookie 7
and the attack continues
so
why did i make this mistake well this
was based on a pure miscalculation
i spent the entire time calculating
essentially queen takes c6 to be honest
and after queen takes f7 i assumed that
i would have enough counter play here
after rook h2 check
i missed the idea of the zigzag king h2
kg3
now
queen takes c6
i thought is more logical
why is it more logical because if black
gives a check on g1 then white goes king
h2 and the queen remains on this
diagonal to stop further checks and
white is winning
who can spot black's strongest move in
this position and according to the
engine black is actually winning already
i saw this move
and i was really hoping that he would go
for this
yeah the idea is rook h1
this is an important type of idea you
cut the king off and then the queen
slides in either to f1 or to g1 with a
devastating attack and there's nothing
why i can do about it
this rook h1 move is easy to miss
because you kind of assume that you have
to give checks and one important kind of
trick
in these positions is to figure out
whether in fact your opponent is
threatening anything like you really
have to do i have time to make a quiet
move and even though it looks like
black's king is surrounded the answer
here is yes because white is not
actually threatening anything specific
so
queen takes f7 i completely
underestimated rook g1
and now
rook h1 and king g3
i had only calculated king f3 after
which queen d1 check happens and at
least black at the very least black will
have a draw
at the very least black will help trust
i thought he was repeating moves but he
actually goes to g3
and
the thing is i should have gone rook g
one check
but after king h4 this essentially
transposes into the game continuation
after queen c3 this was complete panic
and the game should have ended
immediately f3 rook g1 and king h2 would
have forced resignation
now why did i panic here because
let's say the black plays a random move
let's say the black plays
queen back to a1 where is the mate
thank you formless fox the mate is queen
g8
queen h8 and now beautiful queen h4 this
is really nice board geometry and the
king actually supports the queen
so that was the biggest threat that was
the threat i didn't see a defense
against
and
that's why
you know i would have resigned after
king h2
now it turns out that i can play queen
takes c5
and white's winning sequence here is not
a mate
but it is very pretty so queen g8 check
king h6
queen h8 check
king runs out to g5 it looks like
black's king just might escape here h4
check king f4
but in this position white has a
beautiful winning move
which i think can come unexpectedly if
all you're looking for is checkmate but
you actually can't only look for
checkmate you have to look for other
stuff
and that other stuff is to realize that
that rook on g1 is horribly undefended
if you can pry the queen away from c5
you win the game so the move queen f8
check ends the game immediately
queen takes f8 rook takes f8
king moves and you take the what country
one
so i think this is a lovely move queen
fa check
all right
um
so perhaps i should have done that i
i probably would have resigned after
king h2 but amazingly the guy goes king
h4 and allows me to trade queens queen
f6 check and the game continues but
rookie six is incredibly incredibly
accurate
because if he had gone rookie seven
track amazingly white actually loses
after king h6 and g5 mate is unstoppable
so
just uh lots of complications in this
game but he goes rookie six and the
point is that if king h6 now he takes on
f6 just in time to pin my pawn to the
king
and if you go g5 then this is no longer
checkmate king h5
and you don't have time to get the rook
to h3
so i have to defend the pawn now white
is up two pawns and the rest is
very straightforward he extricates his
king from g3
from h4 he trades a pair of pawns in
fact a tribe is very accurate i thought
this was impossible due to stalemate
tricks but i still have a pawn that's
living on f6
and if i play f5 then he throws in a
check on c6 and wins a third pawn all of
which are passed and this was out of the
question
so i tried to hold him down but rook f7
is another incredibly accurate move
followed by rook f5 the final nail in
the coffin or so it seems
if i take on f5 yes white ruins the pawn
structure but it doesn't matter because
he's up two pawns king f7
and g4 h6 and black is in zuk's bunk so
black has no choice but to give up the
last pawn
and that's it the rest is easy obviously
you have to try this it's always worth a
dirty trick
rook d7 rookie 7
so notice what i'm doing first i'm going
back and forth
essentially to get him
to get him into an unsuspecting
situation he doesn't think that i'm all
of a sudden gonna go rookie seven he
thinks i'm just gonna shuffle between d7
and e7 a d7 and c7 and all of a sudden i
go rook
rookie seven obviously he shouldn't have
pre-moved that was a very bad mistake
and now uh
it's still a draw his pawns are so far
advanced that even my rook is not able
to deal with them fully
but black is able to hold here white is
unable to promote the pawns because of
the because there's always going to be
side checks
and it's very nice that um he tried to
get the king around to age six
but now the move rook takes h7 is the
most clinical forcing white either to
lose with king g5 or to take the pawn
with a draw
so
definitely
in my eyes i lost this game i got
outplayed
but no shame in getting outplayed i mean
the guy played
on a on a 2700 level
um i really only made one mistake this
entire game
uh maybe two so
my first mistake was to play queen c7 in
the opening
and my second mistake
um
was to play
was to play the move um
queen a1
apparently rook c1 holds a draw but
this obviously isn't stockfish at a very
high depth so maybe
more precise analysis would indicate
other inaccuracies
um
no he just played a really good game i
think that
everybody's good now
especially at this level
[Music]
yeah it was a very impressive
performance by my opponent without a
doubt i think there were a couple of
moves which were
which were quite impressive
i would point to the g4 move which is
far from intuitive g4 and c5
um
that was impressive and then obviously
the way that he played in the middle
game like b3
rook c1 rook c2 i mean these were
basically forced but still
takes on a4 and rook d2 was very testing
and then i think he he found the
accurate move order here
and then queen f3 actually is a very
very powerful move at least practically
speaking because it poses tremendous
challenges to black
queen a1 and now of course he saw
the way to zigzag the king outside of
the checks so the guy should have won
you know deserve to win the game without
a doubt but
it is what it is
these kinds of things happen
yeah his blitz rating is over 2700 so
clearly a very powerful player
i think he definitely played like a gm
it's possible that he is a gm
i think it's actually quite likely that
he is a gm
um
maybe just not that strong at blitz
because he's a little bit on the slower
side as you could see
but when you give him a lot of time
his
true strength comes out
speedrun made speedrun entirely possible
very likely
[Music]
all right um
all right guys i think we're going to
call it um it's been a really long week
for me i'm feeling pretty tired and i'd
like to take the evening off
um i did do i did do commentary later
earlier today i'm also playing tomorrow
at one o'clock i am playing the um
the pro chess league arena
for california so be sure to tune in
i'll be playing from one to three and
potentially
um if we get second or third place i'll
be playing the playoffs
i'm on a team with min
and york meyer
and a bunch of good people so it's gonna
be a lot of fun
and i probably will stream later tonight
uh sorry
i'm
this is my mental state right now i i
probably will stream
tomorrow
night
i'm thinking maybe around 8 30 9 p.m
eastern
so i'll see you guys tomorrow
thank you for watching
um and appreciate the support i'm going
to raid
yeah let's rate them
maybe we can raid sabine or lafong
yeah let's read sabine
um i i don't think i've ever rated
sabina foyza she is a i think she's a
wgm
um she's very strong and i noticed she
was streaming
pretty frequently lately so
let's give her some love
um and i'll see you guys later
raiding raiding sabine
have a good rest of your weekend bye
everybody thanks for hanging out
[Music]